even though I am not at home right now I
still have my meta course with me so
when Matt asked me if I would just sit
down and watch a video that they've made
I figured it would be right up my alley
so let's do it let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh that's oh my God that's gonna be so
nice to travel with
them whoa
oh my God
that is super exciting okay very excited
about the changes to the side having a
smaller one like this takes up a lot of
space obviously the controllers take up
a lot of space I think a small one
sounds very nice and more clarity is the
thing that I've been wanting for however
many years it's been now so click the
link in my bio to sign up for updates I
know I'm excited to find out more